so because of unforeseen circumstances I
missed the screening of this film last
Tuesday so I went to the Thursday night
showing at nine o'clock which was sold
out the 9:30 was sold out as well so
they opened up in 11:45 p.m. showing and
I went to that despite being pretty
tired I wanted to have my review up last
night but I had to collapse in bed first
so I apologize The Fault in Our Stars is
directed by Josh Boone and star shailene
woodley and Ansel Elgort I apologize if
I butchered your name sir I'm sure we'll
get much pronunciation advice in the
comments below because I always do this
film is based off an extremely popular
novel about a young girl who has cancer
and the film opens with her having
cancer there's no like oh one day I got
cancer is just like I have cancer now
and this is how I have to deal with it
she carries around an oxygen tank
everywhere she goes because it deeply
affects her lungs she's forced to go to
a support group and she meets this guy
who is a cancer survivor but because of
cancer he lost his leg and they become
quick friends and eventually more than
friends and we get to watch their story
of how they come to know each other The
Fault in Our Stars is one of those
movies where as soon as you find out
that it's being made you're like well
that was inevitable because every
popular book especially ones that are
popular with young adults now it's a
movie now and apparently shailene
woodley is gonna star in a lot of them
for me nowadays there's a little bit of
weariness that comes with walking into
another book adaptation to a movie
because there are so many of them
nowadays and it's just becoming this
trend and it seems like so many of them
aren't really given the care that they
deserve The Fault in Our Stars is
gratefully different this is a movie
that is told with quite a bit of care
specifically for its characters shailene
woodley and this film is excellent she
is by far the best part of this movie
her performance is at times
heartbreaking she's extremely real and
she never feels like I'm in a movie look
at me what did he do I'm an actress she
really feels very real in this role and
that is by far one of the best praises
that I can give this movie is the
characters in the film are handled with
quite a bit of love and it really shines
through and the way the actors perform
in this movie because both shailene
woodley and Ansel are very good in their
roles and they definitely have a lot of
obvious care for these characters one of
the things that film tries to do is
defies genre conventions it tries to say
we're going to forget about these
cliches we're going to tell a realistic
story sometimes
act like this happens it sucks but this
is how people deal with it and the film
mostly does a good job of that there are
times where the film does falter and
fall into some of the cliches that it is
trying to avoid but for the most part it
tells a story that has two young people
who are dealing with some really crappy
stuff that happened to them and it shows
the viewpoint of somebody who has
already been through the acceptance
phase its side steps what a lot of
movies that deal with cancer do it skips
the acceptance stuff it skips the denial
stuff and shows two characters that have
already been through all of that and
shows how they deal with it and that was
something I really loved about this
movie the chemistry between the leads
was very good it wasn't mind-blowing ly
great at times but I thought they worked
very well together and a lot of that was
due to the very heartfelt script because
this is a script that at times could
divulge into extreme sappiness and I'm
talking a Lifetime channel original
movie this movie could be truly awful
and there are times where it does feel
like from scene to scene it is just
begging you to cry
but for the most part because of the
realistic portrayal of these characters
and how good the actors did and the
sensitive direction I felt that the
movie wasn't as sappy as it could have
been which is really saying a lot
because of the story that's involved
here this could just go so melodramatic
but they wisely sidestepped a lot of
those more fake scenes that movies try
to get the audience to cry and it just
shows sometimes this is how it is and
this is how people have to deal with
things but like I said earlier there are
some moments in this film that do feel
very cliched that actually go for some
of the cliches that this film is trying
so adamantly to avoid but I got to get
the film props because this story is
just begging to be cheesy and
over-the-top melodramatic but it is able
to avoid a lot of those cliches quite
often and the performances in the film
are very very good the characters are
obviously handled with a lot of emotion
and care and for that reason I'm going
to give the Fault in Our Stars of B it's
a tale that really does feel like it
could happen although sometimes the film
does divulge into some of the cliches
it's trying to avoid so guys are you a
fan of the book what did you guys think
of the book to film adaptation I'm
curious to know your thoughts and as
always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my next